this program is brought to you by Emory
University
as though you ran a marathon and you
know right after you breath I don't know
if you've ever been a runner or Walker
but right after your run or your walk
you get a little exuberant and you'll go
maybe take your shower and you feel
refreshed but if you sit down that wait
you get this weighty feeling like whoo
I'm a little tired it's that feeling
that you can also correlate it with the
filling of flute also for me the
fibromyalgia kind of takes over a lot
and I feel like I'm in a ball and there
are people touching me
that's that chronic pain feeling that I
get and then some days like the past
couple of days it's been more of a
one-sided thing all the way down
everything over that feels tired and not
necessarily off no but I have a stroke
afford to feel like I have a stroke over
there but I didn't get the tingling and
all that kind of stuff so you don't have
those things that's one thing that lupus
will do it will change your schedule
you'll think well I'm supposed to go and
do such-and-such today and then that day
comes and you are just unable to do it
at the lot of time you're sorry but you
just can't do a thing I get to it but I
can't do it when I said I'll try not to
even schedule a whole lot of things or
schedule things with people who will
understand that something could come up
and I may not be able to make it people
can't process us they don't know how to
probably and the disease the disease is
if you don't look if they can't see it
then it's hard to actually digest it and
so it becomes a challenge to how do you
tell your story about how you feel
inwardly when it doesn't match Apple out
on what they see
so my friends that I've met through the
local support group I realize that
they look at me because I don't have the
disco type of blue person rarely is my
face broken out but I was fortunate
enough to have had that dermatologist
early and she was adamant about me doing
things that would keep my skin looking
nice so they look at me and they think
oh you don't have that much going on but
after they got to know me they feel kind
of tight with me now
you
the preceding program is
University